les enjeux de cette réunion consacrée à
l'afghanistan on en parle avec régis le
sommier sur ce plateau il est grand
reporter pour arte france bonjour régis
sergueï lavrov a vient de s'exprimer une
première déclaration du ministre russe
des affaires étrangères
la russie reconnaît je cite les efforts
des talibans pour tenter de stabiliser
l'afghanistan comment est-ce que vous
analysez cette première déclaration
officielle elle dit qu'elle reconnaît
les efforts ne dis pas qu'elle reconnaît
les talibans m union sémantique assez
colossal non je pense que là ya un promo
première prise de contact qui est
intéressant c'est que ça se passe en
effet après le premier rang diplomatique
qui a eu lieu à doha avec les américains
qui a donné des résultats plutôt mitigés
il ya une sorte de
d'observation c'est le round
d'observation
là les russes sont de retour aussi en
afghanistan depuis ils ont comme en ont
depuis longtemps pris langue avec les
talibans là c'est la première visite
officielle
après la reconquête de l'afghanistan
mais y avait déjà eu des pourparlers par
le passé il ya déjà eu aussi des
entretiens avec la chine donc il ya une
sorte de deux constats que voilà les
talibans sont désormais au pouvoir en
afghanistan les efforts pour maintenir
c'est ça ça recoupe une réalité afghane
bien précises c'est à dire que il faut
se mettre dedans dans la tête que
l'afghanistan est un pays extrêmement
difficile à gouverner on l'a vu avec le
précédent gouvernement installé par les
américains et la coalition depuis 2001
qui n'a jamais été capable réellement de
d'asseoir son pouvoir sur l'ensemble du
pays il ya eu de la résistance aux
talibans déjà dans le panchir même si
c'est ça s'est soldé par une défaite de
ses opposants des premiers opposants aux
talibans et il faut savoir que la ligue
est distant est un pays qui se conçoit à
travers sa géographie
c'est une un ensemble de vallées
certaines scènes étant inaccessibles
certaines contenant des populations qui
vivent presque en vase clos avec des
zones à l'est en particulier extrêmement
instable extrêmement difficile à
contrôler évidemment c'est dans ces
zones qu'à prospérer dèche à une époque
dont qaïs khorassan qui aujourd'hui
montrent le bout du nez à travers des
attentats spectaculaires contre des
mosquées chiites en particulier mais
aussi contre lui au moment des obsèques
de l'un des porte-parole des taliban
donc il ya véritablement une menace est
en train de se mettre en place et une
menace qui peut amener qui peut créer de
l'instabilité je pense que la plupart
des pays occidentaux de la russie et de
la chine s'inquiète justement de cette
situation qui pourrait dégénérer et qui
pourrait voir des groupes à vocation
terroriste international prendre souche
en afghanistan et éventuellement monter
des opérations de déstabilisation ou
dans les anciennes républiques
soviétiques du sud du nord de
l'afghanistan où également dans la zone
oui vous voir c'est à dire la zone
musulmane de chine donc il ya un enjeu
colossal ici et est donc je pense que
tout c'est tout c'est comment ces
pourparlers sont là pour essayer de voir
un peu plus clair sur ce qui va se
passer et comment la situation pourrait
évoluer justement tous ces pays ils sont
présents à cette réunion qui a lieu donc
à moscou une dizaine de pays ont
représenté par les divers délégation on
a dit donc les talibans les chinois les
russes les pakistanais les iraniens sont
présents les indiens également mais pas
les américains alors que vous l'avez dit
il y avait eu un derby d'observation
comme vous l'avez dit du côté de doha
avec les occidentaux pourquoi
c'est de réunions à deux endroits
différents avec des acteurs différentes
écoutez ce d'abord c'est pas la première
fois on l'a vu sur la crise syrienne
pendant des années les propos des
pourparlers à genève et puis après
street est pour moi la prius astana qui
s'est créée l'acquis de la situation est
évidemment totalement différente ici
mais l'idée d'ouvrir des rentes de
négociation ou
périphérique n'est pas nouvelle je
rappellerai que les américains ont été
invités à moscou et qui n'ont pas
souhaité s'y rendre peut-être aussi
parce que pour le moment les américains
sont dans une période comment dire où
ils subissent encore
les effets de cette évacuation
catastrophique qui a quand même
substantiellement ternit leur image même
si elle était nécessaire même si il
fallait un moment que les américains
s'en aille 1 c'est 1,1 comme en état de
fait qui a été actée depuis barack obama
s'est pas simplement joe biden qui a
décidé de retirer les troupes et de
partir de quitter l'afghanistan pour de
bon c'est trois trois mandatures
américaine pendant lesquelles ce retrait
s'est opérée avec une accélération au
moment de de commandes donald trump mais
le pour les ponts et pour parler de deux
doigts on peut dire quand même
aujourd'hui sont quand même entâché
d'échec puisque selon essayer de faire
des américains avec les talibans la
seule chose qu'ils ont réussi c'est de
faire la paix avec eux et de faire en
sorte que les talibans n'attaque plus
leur armée à partir de février 2020 mais
ensuite tout ce qu'ils ont tenté de
faire salaires d'inclure des figures de
l'opposition au gouvernement de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait un dialogue entre le
gouvernement et les talibans tout ça a
échoué des talibans ont repris le
pouvoir pour nos moyens aucune figure de
l'opposition qui est dans le
gouvernement taliban on avait même parlé
d'une femme un moment c'est hors de
question est ce qu'on a vu dans la
représentation dans la répartition des
postes c'est toutes les sensibilités
différentes au sein du mouvement taliban
que ce soit le réseau haqqani qui est
présent comment la tradition et que
jakub halle fils du mollah omar et puis
une aile entre guillemets plus modérée
avec le mollah baradar qui était le chef
des négociateurs
avec les américains à doha et qui
représente une forme de weeds elle
modérés des talibans dont trois en gros
on a un gouvernement inclusif d un
gouvernement inclusif de talibans on a
pété les plombs n'a pas le reste de la
société et c'était les demandes que les
américains avaient formulé c'est aussi
ce sont aussi des demandes que la
communauté internationale a fait pour le
moment on n'a pas vu de 2,2 de
changement
hélas la communauté internationale sans
les américains présentent ici du côté de
moscou est ce que il va y avoir une
demande également ou est-ce que c'est
pas à l'ordre du jour
quel est le
quels sont les intérêts des pays
représentés aujourd'hui à moscou la
russie la chine l'inde leur intérêt sais
quoi parce qu'on sait que les
britanniques les soviétiques les
américains sont cassé les dents en
afghanistan maintenant c'est quoi c'est
vivre avec l'afghanistan des talibans de
toute façon c'est un état de fait les
talibans sont sont sont revenus au
pouvoir ils sont tous pouvoirs bon on il
cherche la reconnaissance internationale
sur bien sûr mais cette reconnaissance
internationale et c'est là où il ya
encore peut être un levier que la
communauté internationale peut activer
c'est à dire sur un certain nombre de
points il ya la question sécuritaire qui
est très importante pour les russes très
importante pour les chinois très
importante pour toutes les républiques
qui sont justes et j'en parlais tout à
l'heure au nord de l'afghanistan et
également pour le pakistan dont il ya
une sorte de comment dire de
voilà de round d'observation pour savoir
comment les talibans vont gouverner
l'afghanistan et ans vers serré il ya
des demandes qui ont été formulés de la
part de la communauté internationale en
particulier de l'union européenne sur la
question du traitement des femmes sur la
question des droits de l'homme sur la
question de deux du gouvernement et du
type de gouvernement que les talibans
vont imposer en afghanistan et là il ya
un levier parce qu'il ya une question
cruciale pour les talibans c'est de
pouvoir se maintenir au pouvoir et aussi
de pouvoir nourrir leurs pays leurs
peuples actuellement il ya environ un
tiers des afghans qui sont en risque de
famine on arrive dans les mois d'hiver
la zone de bamiyan par exemple il ya pu
rien à manger je pense ça en particulier
parce que j'ai quelques contacts dans
cette dans ce nom ce coup dans cet
endroit c'est très critiques donc il ya
un besoin d' aide internationale et ce
qu'ils essayent de faire la communauté
internationale c'est de justement
corrélés cette aide à un certain nombre
de critères que les talibans
respecterait en échange justement d'une
aide donc la vieille à des leviers de
négociation verser sécurité droits de
l'homme droits des femmes il ya tout un
tas il ya une palette de et on a
l'impression qu'actuellement la
communauté internationale serait partie
justement et le terrorisme qui plus une
question que les kikis intéressés
américain même si les russes évidemment
sont très attentifs à ce que ce qui va
se passer en afghanistan n'oublions pas
d'afghanistan était le sanctuaire d'al
qaïda c'est de là que son parti qui ont
été formés et recrutés les kamikazes du
11-septembre ça a été une zone
d'instabilité et une zone productrice de
terrorisme à l'international et là tout
le monde est concerné par sa merci régis
le sommier pour votre décryptage est
votre analyse de la situation en
afghanistan je rappelle que vous êtes
grand reporter pour arte france